Elena's dad moved to China, but here's the kind of thing that he does. On Christmas Eve every year, Elena and her mom drive from Madison, Wisconsin, to her grandmother's down in Chicago.
埃琳娜的父亲搬到了中国，但他总会做这样的事：每年平安夜，埃琳娜和她妈妈都会从威斯康星州的麦迪逊开车去芝加哥看望祖母。
So he-- since he's overseas, he doesn't make that trip with us anymore. So he'll watch the weather, and send me emails about how the drive's going to be.
所以他——既然人在海外，他就没法再和我们一起开车了。因此他会关注天气，并给我发邮件，提醒我路上开车的情况。
A recent email began comparing the temperatures in Wisconsin with temperatures in Illinois, and warning her that quote "the greater danger will lie in the colder Wisconsin portion, hazardously slipping from water to ice and back." Elena read me the letter.
最近的一封邮件开始比较威斯康星州和伊利诺伊州的气温，并警告她说，引用“更大的危险在于威斯康星州较冷的路段，那里极易出现水结冰、冰融化的危险打滑。”埃琳娜读了那封信给我听。
"Icy conditions could suddenly appear, particularly on bridges and overpasses. In such conditions, I test periodically by first slowing down, then, with no traffic around, just touch the brakes a bit to test for slippage. If any at all, slow down and maintain plenty of distance from cars ahead. Let the fools and cowboys roar on to their wreckage."
“冰滑路段可能会突然出现，特别是在桥梁和立交桥上。在这种情况下，我会定期测试，首先减速，然后在周围没有车辆时，轻轻踩一下刹车来测试是否有打滑。如果有一点打滑，就减速并与前车保持足够的距离。让那些傻瓜和鲁莽的司机去撞车吧。”
You can't that? "Let the fools and cowboys roar on to their wreckage." In case you're wondering, when Elena got this letter, she had been driving in snow and ice for over a decade.
你信吗？“让那些傻瓜和鲁莽的司机去撞车吧。”如果你好奇的话，埃琳娜收到这封信时，她已经在雪地和冰面上开了十多年的车了。
"If you feel yourself slipping, steer gently towards the edge of the highway where the crusty, accumulated snow and ice may keep you from spinning out. Sometimes there's a residue of sand on the shoulder and coarser pavement to grip. Sorry to give you advice, but I'm just passing on the fruits of a million miles in all kinds of weather. Love to all, Dad."
“如果你感觉自己正在打滑，轻轻转向高速公路边缘，那里堆积的坚硬雪冰可能会防止你打转。有时路肩上有残留的沙子和较粗糙的路面可以提供抓地力。抱歉给你建议，但我只是在传递我数百万英里各种天气下驾驶的经验成果。祝大家好，爸爸。”
So what did you make of that?
那你对此怎么看？
Well, I mean, it's pretty typical. I said it reminds me of a manual for someone who's never driven in winter before. It's a mix of, I rolled my eyes, and, oh gosh, here we go again. But, at the same time, I thought it was really sweet and endearing. You know?
嗯，我的意思是，这很典型。我说这让我想起了一本为从未在冬季开车的人准备的手册。这混合了我翻白眼的感觉，还有“哦天哪，又来了”的感觉。但与此同时，我觉得这真的很贴心、很可爱。你知道吗？
Dads, man. We guys can have a hard time reaching out and telling our kids we love them. Take Jessica, whose father, a farmer who didn't really show his feelings much through physical affection. One day, when she was around 14, out of the blue walked up to her, and started patting her on the shoulder. And she says, soon he was doing this all the time. He did this every day to her.
爸爸们，唉。我们男人很难主动去告诉孩子们我们爱他们。看看杰西卡吧，她父亲是个农民，不太通过肢体接触表达感情。有一天，当她大约14岁时，他突然走到她身边，开始拍拍她的肩膀。她说，很快他经常这样做。他每天都对她这样做。
But eventually it came to a point where I really, really disliked it. I would dread it. I would know it was coming. I could hear him approaching behind. And even developed a sense to realize, where is my dad? When is this going to happen?
但最终我真的非常非常讨厌它。我会感到害怕。我会知道它要来了。我能听到他在后面靠近。甚至练就了一种感应，意识到，我爸爸在哪里？这什么时候会发生？
She asked him to stop, he wasn't able to stop. She couldn't understand this behavior. And then she found out from her mom that her dad had been listening to a show on Christian radio, she thinks it was probably James Dobson, and he heard somebody on the show give the advice that people in your family need to be touched a certain number of times per day in order to feel loved. And this was how he was going to do it.
她请求他停止，但他无法停止。她无法理解这种行为。后来她从妈妈那里得知，她爸爸一直在听基督教广播节目，她觉得可能是詹姆斯·多布森的节目，他听到节目里有人建议说，家庭成员每天需要一定数量的身体接触才能感受到爱。而这就是他打算采取的方式。
What if your dad had actually done this in a way where it was clear that what it was about is that he was trying to show you that he loved you? In other words, what if your dad-- you'd be in the kitchen, and your dad would be in the kitchen, and just out of the blue he would say, hey, I love you. Give me a hug. Would that have worked?
如果你的爸爸以一种明确的方式表达他这么做是因为他想向你证明他爱你呢？换句话说，如果你的爸爸——你在厨房，你爸爸也在厨房，他突然说，嘿，我爱你。给我个拥抱。那样会管用吗？
Um, I would have thought something was wrong with him. Like having a breakdown or something. Then it would have been, Mom, what is wrong with Dad? Yeah, because it's not really his personality either. He's a little doomed in this.
嗯，我会以为他出了什么问题。就像精神崩溃什么的。然后我会问，妈妈，爸爸怎么了？是的，因为这也不是他的性格。他在这方面有点注定要失败。
Still, guys want to reach out to their kids, right? In 2005, when Rachel was about to head off to college in New York, one night her family's sitting around watching TV--
尽管如此，男人们还是想和孩子亲近，对吧？2005年，当瑞秋即将去纽约上大学时，一天晚上，她全家坐在一起看电视——
And my dad just turned to me and was, like, I'm building you an emergency terrorist attack kit to take with you to New York City.
我爸爸突然转向我说，他正在为我准备一个紧急恐怖袭击应急包，让我带去纽约市。
An emergency terrorist attack kit.
一个紧急恐怖袭击应急包。
It was completely out of nowhere. But I looked at my mom. And my dad has this one particular face he makes when you must take him seriously. His eyebrows get raised, and his eyes go really wide. And he stares at you. And he was doing that, so I didn't argue about it.
这完全是没来由的。但我看了看妈妈。我爸爸有一种特殊的表情，当你必须认真对待他时就会看到。他的眉毛扬起，眼睛睁得很大。他盯着你看。当时他就是那种表情，所以我没有争辩。
So the whole summer, my dad would find these different items to pack. Some of them were from weird Internet locations. You can only get a universal radio that did not require electricity that worked with every cell phone from a crazy website. This is not something they sell at every store. So he ordered this special radio, he ordered a NASA issued space blanket and flares and fuel pellets for a stove you only needed fuel pellets for. Potassium iodide pills, in the event of a nuclear attack. He was really proud every time he found a new object. Every time he thought of a new thing, he'd say, "I found something new for the box." And I'd laugh, I guess, because what else can you really do but laugh? And find it really one of those, oh Dad, type of things.
整个夏天，我爸爸都会寻找各种物品来打包。有些是从奇怪的互联网渠道买的。你只能从一个疯狂的网站买到一个不需要电的万能收音机，它适用于所有手机。这不是每个商店都卖的东西。所以他订购了这个特制的收音机，他订购了NASA颁发的太空毯、信号弹和燃料球，给一种只需要燃料球的炉子用。碘化钾药片，以防核袭击。每次他找到一个新物品，他都感到非常自豪。每次他想到一个新东西，他都会说，“我给箱子找了个新东西。”我会笑，我想，因为除了笑你还能做什么呢？并觉得这真是那种“哦爸爸”类型的事情。
So it comes time to go to school, Rache's dad packs all the gear into a nondescript three by three cardboard box, seals it up tightly with tape. Writes "Winter Coats" on the side so as not attract any attention, you know, from the wrong element. And then he sends Rachel off to college in the city that is, to be fair, probably the nation's most likely target for any terrorist attack. And he gives Rachel just one instruction, don't open this unless there's an attack. And she follows that instruction for a year. And for a second year.
去上学的时间到了，瑞秋的爸爸把所有的装备装进一个不起眼的3x3纸箱里，用胶带封得很紧。在侧面写上“冬大衣”，以免引起注意，你知道，被某些坏人盯上。然后他把瑞秋送到那个城市去上大学，平心而论，那里可能是全国最容易受到恐怖袭击的目标。他给了瑞秋唯一一个指示，不到受到袭击不要打开这个箱子。她遵守了这个指示一年。第二年也遵守了。
So I knew that there was $200 in there, and I was about to leave for London for my junior year. And I really wanted to go tanning before the summer really started, so I just decided to open the box and take out the $200. And I actually, when I did open it to get the money out, there was a letter inside from my dad that basically said, you know, if you're reading this, your mom and I love you and it was just-- oh my God, I'm actually get choked up thinking about it, I've never gotten choked up think about it-- but it was basically a letter. Just saying, if you're reading this, something really bad has happened. I just want you to know that your mom and I really, really love you. And everything's going to be fine.
所以我知道里面有200美元，我正要离开去伦敦读大三。我真的很想在夏天真正开始前去美黑，所以我决定打开箱子取出那200美元。当我打开它拿钱时，里面实际上有一封我爸爸的信，基本内容是说，你知道，如果你在读这封信，我和妈妈爱你，而且它只是——哦天哪，想到这个我真的哽咽了，我从来没有因为想到这个而哽咽过——但基本上那是一封信。只是说，如果你在读这封信，说明发生了非常糟糕的事情。我只是想让你知道，我和妈妈真的、真的非常爱你。一切都会好起来的。
You know, my dad and I, we talk, and we communicate. But neither one of is very good at talking about our feelings. And it was just really sweet. It was really sincere. It was like one of the most sincere things I've ever gotten from him.
你知道，我和爸爸，我们交谈，我们沟通。但我们都不擅长谈论我们的感受。这真的很贴心。这真的很真诚。这是我从他那里得到的、最真诚的事情之一。
Well, today on our radio show, for Father's Day, we have stories of dads reaching out to kids in very dad-like ways, which-- I mean, these stories anyway-- means that dads are not always so direct in saying their feelings. They use the tools that they know. Which means instructions. Which means disaster preparedness. Or, like my dad, one of the big ways that he can show his love is by helping me every year with my taxes, which I love. I love my dad.
今天在我们的广播节目中，为了父亲节，我们收集了一些爸爸们用非常“爸爸式”的方式与孩子亲近的故事，这意味着——我的意思是，这些故事至少说明——爸爸们在表达感情时并不总是那么直接。他们使用他们知道的工具。这意味着指令。这意味着防灾准备。或者，像我爸爸一样，他表达爱的一种主要方式是每年帮我报税，我很喜欢。我爱我的爸爸。
Anyway, we have Jonathan Goldstein, we have Michael Ian Black, we have a dad who was not born in this country and has yet to learn the ways of American dads, which are very, very tricky. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass, stay with us.
无论如何，我们有乔纳森·戈德斯坦，我们有迈克尔·伊恩·布莱克，还有一位不是出生在这个国家、尚未学会美国爸爸们那一套的爸爸，那些方式非常非常棘手。来自芝加哥WBEZ，这是《美国生活》，由公共广播国际发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯，请继续收听。
Act one, "Astro boy meet robot dad." We start with this story of a dad and kid and the space between them. From Michael Ian Black.
第一幕，“天文小子遇见机器人老爸”。我们从这个关于父亲和孩子以及他们之间距离的故事开始。来自迈克尔·伊恩·布莱克。
My own father wasn't the best father. Not because he didn't love us, but because he simply didn't know how to be around kids. He wasn't socially adept with adults, either, but with children he was hopeless. He didn't wrestle Or make dumb faces. Or play catch. Once he bought me a baseball mitt for my birthday, which I loved, except for the fact that I am a lefty and he bought me a right-handed mitt. It seemed equally possible to me that he was either unaware that baseball mitts came for both righties and lefties, or that he did not know that I am left-handed.
我自己的父亲并不是最好的父亲。不是因为他不爱我们，而是因为他根本不知道该如何和孩子相处。他与成年人社交也不在行，但对孩子他简直无可救药。他不摔跤，不做鬼脸。也不玩投接球。有一次他给我买了一个棒球手套作为生日礼物，我很喜欢，除了一个事实：我是左撇子，而他给我买的是右手手套。我觉得这两种可能性一样大：要么他不知道棒球手套有左右之分，要么他不知道我是左撇子。
He was the first person I ever knew who owned his own computer. It was a hulking Tandy TRS-80. It did so much less than my brother and I did, and yet he spent so much more time interacting with the computer than with us. A popular activity with my dad on the weekends, when we visited him, was to hand my brother and I each a plastic bucket and tell us to go outside and pick the rocks out of his lawn. He called the game "go pick up rocks." So much fun.
他是我认识的第一个拥有自己电脑的人。那是一台笨重的Tandy TRS-80。它能做的事情远少于我和我哥哥能做的，然而他花在电脑上的时间远多于陪伴我们。周末我们去看他时，他的一项流行活动是给我们兄弟俩每人一个塑料桶，让我们去外面把草坪里的石头捡出来。他把这个游戏叫作“去捡石头”。真有趣。
Here's how he died. One night, the police find him pulled over in his car on the side of the highway. He's unconscious, with a head injury, the apparent victim of an assault. They think it occurred in the parking lot at Rutgers University, where he is taking night classes to get his Master's degree. He's 39 years old. He is brought to the hospital where doctors perform emergency brain surgery.
他去世的过程是这样的：一天晚上，警察发现他的车停在高速公路边。他昏迷不醒，头部受伤，显然是袭击的受害者。他们认为这发生在罗格斯大学的停车场，他在那里上夜校攻读硕士学位。他39岁。他被送往医院，医生对他进行了紧急脑部手术。
My brother Rick and I aren't told until the following day, after he is out of immediate danger. My brother and I visit him there a couple days later. I don't remember who took us, Mom or his second wife, Beth. My parents have been divorced for seven years, and the relationship is terrible. So it is probably Beth.
直到第二天他脱离危险后，我和哥哥瑞克才被告知。几天后，我和哥哥去医院看他。我不记得是谁带我们去的，妈妈还是他的第二任妻子贝丝。我父母已经离婚七年了，关系很糟糕。所以很可能是贝丝。
He's distant, and foggy, but recovering. Then one morning, we're asleep in our bunk beds. It's early. A school day. I hear Mom come into the room. "Boys, wake up," she says. My eyes open. She's standing beside our bed, where she can see us both. She is unhesitant. "Your father died last night."
他很疏远，意识模糊，但在康复中。然后一天早上，我们在上下铺床上睡觉。天还没亮。是个上学日。我听到妈妈走进房间。“孩子们，起床了，”她说。我睁开眼睛。她站在我们床边，可以看到我们俩。她没有犹豫。“你爸爸昨晚去世了。”
She says it quick, almost blowing the words out with her breath. "The hospital gave him a medicine he was allergic to. An accident. I'm so sorry," she says. She begins weeping huge convulsive sobs. "I'm so sorry," she says, again and again. She runs from the room, leaving Rick and me alone.
她说得很快，几乎是随着呼吸把话吹出来。“医院给了他一种他过敏的药。一场意外。我很抱歉，”她说。她开始发出巨大的、抽搐的啜泣声。“我很抱歉，”她一遍又一遍地说。她跑出了房间，留下瑞克和我独自在那儿。
The news is so swift and shocking that I cannot process it at all. Dead? In what way, dead? Above me, I hear Rick began to cry, and after a moment I start crying, too. Because I don't know what else to do. Crying seems like the appropriate response, and I'm still young enough, 12, that I can summon tears without too much effort. We lay in bed doing that for a while, and I wonder if I will have to go to school today. No. No school today, or for the rest of the week.
这个消息太迅速、太令人震惊，我根本无法消化。死了？怎么个死法？在我上方，我听到瑞克开始哭泣，过了一会儿，我也开始哭。因为我不知道该做什么。哭泣似乎是合适的反应，而且我还很小，12岁，我可以毫不费力地流下眼泪。我们在床上躺了一会儿，我想我今天是不是不用去上学了。是的。今天不用去学校，这周也不用了。
Mom takes Rick and me to work with her that day, because there's nothing else for us to do. She and her partner Arlene own a small stationery store in a crummy flea market. The day passes in a haze. We don't talk about Dad. We don't talk about anything. On our way home, we stop at the video store. Mom tells us we can pick out whatever movie we want. We choose The Blues Brothers , which is rated R. Normally, we are not allowed to rent R-rated movies. She glances at the box but doesn't say anything. Awesome.
妈妈那天带瑞克和我去上班，因为我们没什么别的事可做。她和她的伴侣阿琳在一个破旧的跳蚤市场拥有一家小型文具店。这一天在浑浑噩噩中度过。我们没谈论爸爸。我们什么都没谈。在回家的路上，我们在录像带店停下。妈妈告诉我们可以挑选任何我们想要的电影。我们选择了《福禄双霸天》，那是R级电影。通常我们是不被允许租R级电影的。她瞥了一眼盒子，但什么也没说。太棒了。
A small, shameful part of me begins to see the upside to Dad dying. For the foreseeable future, it seems like I will get away with whatever I want. Staying up late, R-rated movies. Maybe even the Holy Grail of childhood contraband, sugar cereals. Our cereal cupboard is normally filled with high-fiber, lesbian-friendly cereals, like Product 19 and Special K. Yes, Arlene is her partner and her partner. Surely a boy who has just lost his father is not to be denied a box or two of Frosted Flakes in his grief. Surely not.
我内心一个微小而可耻的部分开始看到父亲去世的好处。在可预见的未来，我似乎可以做任何我想做的事。熬夜，看R级电影。甚至可能是童年违禁品的圣杯，糖渍麦片。我们的麦片柜通常装满高纤维、女同性恋友好的麦片，比如19号产品和Special K。是的，阿琳是她的伴侣。一个刚失去父亲的男孩，在悲伤中肯定不会被拒绝来一两盒磨砂玉米片。肯定不会。
Even as I am having these thoughts, I am aware what a horrible person I must be. Who thinks like this? Who thinks about using the death of a parent as a means to get sugar? As it turns out, me. Why do I not feel tormented with grief? Isn't that what you're supposed to feel when a parent dies? Am I defective?
即使我在有这些想法的同时，我也意识到我一定是一个多么可怕的人。谁会这么想？谁会想利用父母的死亡作为获取糖分的手段？结果证明，是我。为什么我没有感到被悲伤折磨？难道父母去世时你不应该感到悲伤吗？我是不是有缺陷？
We have nothing to do before the funeral two days from now, so Rick and I sit around the basement by ourselves, watching game shows and soap operas. We don't talk about it. Anyway, what is there to say? "It sucks that Dad died." "Pretty much." "Can you turn The Price is Right on?" "Sure."
在两天后的葬礼前，我们无事可做，所以瑞克和我独自坐在地下室里，看游戏节目和肥皂剧。我们没有讨论它。无论如何，有什么好说的呢？“爸爸去世了真糟糕。”“差不多吧。”“你能把《价格猜猜猜》打开吗？”“当然。”
I keep flashing back to an incident that happened a year or so before, when Dad was dropping us off at home after one of our weekends with him. He was not a demonstrative man, and it occurred to me that I couldn't remember him ever telling me that he loved me. I didn't doubt that he did, but he'd never said it, and I had never said it to him. So I decided to tell him I loved him. I'm not sure why I felt the need to do it at that moment, it just seemed important.
我不断回想起一年前发生的一件事，那时爸爸在我们度完周末后送我们回家。他不是一个感情外露的人，我突然意识到我不记得他曾经告诉过我他爱我。我并不怀疑他爱我，但他从未说过，我也从未对他说过。所以我决定告诉他我爱他。我不确定为什么我当时感到有必要这么做，这似乎很重要。
That night, I waited for Rick and our younger sister Susan to get out of the car. When they were clear, I gathered up my courage, and blurted out, "I love you, Dad." Then I ran from the car, up the sidewalk, and into the house. If he responded, I never heard. That's what I keep thinking about in the basement as Rick and I watch the Big Showcase Showdown wheel on The Price is Right , spinning on its axis, around and around and around.
那天晚上，我等瑞克和我们年幼的妹妹苏珊下车。当他们都走开后，我鼓起勇气，脱口而出：“我爱你，爸爸。”然后我跑出车子，跑上人行道，跑进了屋子。如果他回应了，我没听见。这就是我在地下室里，当瑞克和我看着《价格猜猜猜》里的大展示赛轮盘在轴上旋转、旋转、旋转时，我一直想的事情。
The next day, our stepmother Beth picks us up, and we drive with her to the funeral home, a saggy, Gothic house near the highway. Inside, the place suffocates from wood and carpet. Beth asks if I want to go into the viewing where they've got Dad. "In a minute," I say, taking a seat on the bench in the hallway. She and Rick walk  in to the room together, and I sit by myself.
第二天，我们的继母贝丝来接我们，我们和她一起开车去殡仪馆，那是高速公路附近一栋松垮的哥特式房子。里面，那个地方充斥着木头和地毯味。贝丝问我是否想进瞻仰厅看爸爸。“等一下，”我说，在走廊的长椅上坐下。她和瑞克一起走进了房间，我独自坐着。
I do not want to go in. Absolutely do not want to go. It's going to be creepy and I do not care for creepy things. Even Scooby Doo stresses me out. There's a lot of people milling around that I do not recognize. Work friends, maybe. People he knew from his neighborhood. My aunt Jane is also there with our cousins.
我不想进去。绝对不想进去。这会让人毛骨悚然，我不喜欢毛骨悚然的东西。连《史酷比》都会让我感到压力。有很多我不认识的人在走动。可能是工作上的朋友。他邻里认识的人。我的姑姑简和我们的表亲们也在那里。
My father's father, who we rarely see, is there. What's it like for him? He doesn't say much. He doesn't cry, and he doesn't hug me or even shake my hand. All in all, he seems remarkably unperturbed. He used to be a cop. He lives another 25 years, but I never see him again.
我父亲的父亲，我们很少见，也在那里。他感觉如何？他不怎么说话。他不哭，也不抱我，甚至没和我握手。总而言之，他看起来异常平静。他曾经是一名警察。他又活了25年，但我再也没见过他。
Somebody checks on me. Am I OK? I nod, yeah, yeah. Never better. My new suit is uncomfortable and itchy around the armpits. Also I feel like I can't breathe and I might throw up. I'm good.
有人过来看我。我没事吧？我点点头，没事，没事。好得不能再好了。我的新西装在腋下很不舒服，很痒。我也觉得喘不过气来，可能会吐。我很好。
Michael Ian Black reading an excerpt from this book that he's writing called You're Not Doing It Right , which comes out early next year. He has a stand-up comedy special airing on Comedy Central this August.
迈克尔·伊恩·布莱克正在朗读他写的书《你做得不对》的节选，该书将于明年年初出版。他有一个单口喜剧特辑将于今年八月在喜剧中心播出。
[MUSIC -- "PAPA WAS TOO" BY JOE TEX]
[音乐——“爸爸也曾经”]
Act two, "I just called to say-- something that is very hard to say, that I really should say more often..." Well, now we'll hear another case study of a dad who has trouble saying a certain phrase to his child. And the dad in this case gets put to the test. Jonathan Menjivar has this story about this tough dad, and his now tough-skinned kid.
第二幕，“我打电话只是为了说——一句很难说出口，但我确实应该更常说的话……”好吧，现在我们将听到另一个关于一位父亲难以对孩子说出特定短语的案例。而这位父亲面临了考验。乔纳森·门吉瓦尔带来了一个关于这位强硬的父亲和他现在脸皮变厚的孩子的故事。
The kid in the story is a girl. Her name is Naomi Azar and she's the youngest of four kids. The baby. She's in her 30s now, but she says that as a child she was afraid of her dad. So her sister would hold her hand--
故事里的孩子是个女孩。她叫娜奥米·阿扎尔，是四个孩子中最小的一个。那个“小宝宝”。她现在30多岁了，但她说小时候她很怕她爸爸。所以她姐姐会牵着她的手——
And my sister would take me to him and gently help me stroke his back, to teach me that he's OK, he's not going to bite.
我姐姐会带我去找他，轻轻帮我抚摸他的背，教我他很好，他不会咬人。
Like he was a Doberman or something. He was that intense. His name is Shaul Azar, and he's one of those immigrant tough dads. He was born in the Middle East. As a kid, he sold chickens on the black market. And then he came to America and, from nothing, he starts his own real estate business. The guy owns more than 30 buildings in Chicago now.
就像他是一条杜宾犬什么的。他就是那么强势。他的名字是沙尔·阿扎尔，他是那种移民过来的强硬派父亲。他在中东出生。小时候，他在黑市卖鸡。然后他来到美国，从零开始，创办了自己的房地产公司。这家伙现在在芝加哥拥有30多栋建筑。
And if that part sounds familiar, this will too. I don't know why, but immigrant dads seem to follow a sort of script. I say this as someone who is the son of an immigrant dad.
如果那部分听起来很熟悉，这一部分也会。我不知道为什么，但移民爸爸似乎总是遵循某种剧本。我是作为一个移民父亲的儿子这么说的。
Anyhow, Naomi dad's Shaul, he could be harsh. He once called Naomi stupid and ungrateful because she was chopping peppers the wrong way. But he was sweet, too, almost sappy. When Naomi was 18, he took her on a trip to Egypt and Jordan. Just the two of them.
无论如何，娜奥米的爸爸沙尔，他有时很苛刻。他曾因为娜奥米切胡椒的方式不对而骂她愚蠢且忘恩负义。但他也很贴心，甚至有点多愁善感。娜奥米18岁时，他带她去埃及和约旦旅行。只有他们两个。
Naomi said she knew her dad loved her, but he never expressed it. He worked all the time. Gave his kids everything they needed. That's the way he said I love you.
娜奥米说她知道她爸爸爱她，但他从不表达。他总是忙着工作。给孩子们他们需要的一切。那就是他表达“我爱你”的方式。
I don't really remember hearing him really say those words. I think the only time I started to hear him tell me that he loved me was when I started to tell him, regularly, that I loved him. Some dads would get off the phone and automatically say "I love you." He'll say, "Thank you very much."
我不记得真的听到他说过这些话。我想我开始听到他说爱我的唯一时候，是我开始定期告诉他我爱他的时候。有些爸爸挂断电话会自动说“我爱你”。他会说，“非常感谢。”
Which is why it was weird when Naomi started getting these calls from her dad. Shaul had been at dinner with one of Naomi's sisters. Her sister's husband is a rabbi. And at dinner, the cantor from his synagogue is there with his wife. And Shaul is arguing with her-- it doesn't really matter what it was about-- but eventually, the cantor's wife turns to Naomi's dad and asks him if he loves his children.
这就是为什么当娜奥米开始接到她爸爸的这些电话时觉得很奇怪。沙尔曾和娜奥米的一位姐妹共进晚餐。她姐妹的丈夫是拉比。晚餐时，他犹太教堂的领唱和他的妻子也在场。沙尔正在和她争论——争论的内容不重要——但最终，领唱的妻子转向娜奥米的爸爸，问他是否爱他的孩子们。
The cantor's wife basically called him on the fact that he feels all this love and respect for his children-- she's assuming, but I believe he does-- but that he doesn't ever express it. And really he should be telling us that he loves us.
领唱的妻子基本上是当面指出他虽然对孩子们怀有深沉的爱和尊重——她假设是这样，我相信他确实有——但他从不表达。他确实应该告诉我们他爱我们。
And she basically asks him to prove it. She gives him this challenge. She tells Shaul, I want you to call each of your four children, every day, for a month. And when you call them, I want you to tell them "I love you." Naomi was on vacation when he called the first time.
她基本上要求他证明这一点。她给了他这个挑战。她告诉沙尔，我希望你一个月内每天给你的四个孩子每人打一个电话。打电话时，我希望你告诉他们“我爱你”。沙尔第一次打电话时，娜奥米正在度假。
Naomi, this is Daddy [? Warbuck ?]. I heard that you rented a cabin and you're having fun. I'm very, very proud of you. And somebody, you know, the cantor's wife, Sydney, said to me I should call up all my children every day and tell them that I love them. So I'm doing what she tells me to do.
娜奥米，我是爸爸。听说你租了个小屋玩得很开心。我非常非常为你感到骄傲。有人，你知道，领唱的妻子，悉尼，告诉我应该每天给我所有的孩子打电话告诉他们我爱他们。所以我正在做她告诉我的事情。
And she's the first one.
你是第一个。
OK, and you are the first one I am calling. Does it make any difference? Let me know, please. Bye.
好了，你是第一个我打电话的人。这有什么区别吗？请让我知道。再见。
I was really surprised, and I was really touched. It was really sweet to hear him say it, and even just the tone of his voice around it. Like, my dad, really? He's going to call me every day? He's going to do that kind of thing? He is going to open himself up in this way?
我真的很惊讶，也很感动。听到他说这些话真的很贴心，甚至连他说话的语气都很动人。就像，我爸爸，真的吗？他要每天给我打电话？他要做那种事？他要以这种方式敞开心扉？
He didn't call the next day. But the day after that, he tried to make up for it, though he clearly has his eyes on the finish line.
他第二天没打。但再过一天，他试图弥补，尽管他显然盯着终点线。
Naomi, this is the third day, and I missed yesterday. So I'm telling you twice. I love you, one for yesterday. And I love you, one for today. I cannot wait until the month is over.
娜奥米，这是第三天，我昨天错过了。所以我告诉你两次。我爱你，一次是昨天的。我爱你，一次是今天的。我迫不及待想等到一个月结束了。
Naomi, this is the third day. I'm saying love you again. Twenty-seven days left. So, what have you been doing, did it snow in New York?
娜奥米，这是第三天。我又说了一遍我爱你。还有27天。所以，你一直在做什么，纽约下雪了吗？
The next day he didn't call, or the day after that. Or the one after that either. Three days. That's all he could handle. His big experiment was over.
第二天他没打，之后那一天也没打。再后来那一天也没打。三天。这就是他所能坚持的全部。他伟大的实验结束了。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
Hello?
喂？
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE].
[外语]
This is of course Naomi's dad, Shaul Azar.
这当然是娜奥米的爸爸，沙尔·阿扎尔。
So I want to introduce you to Jonathan, he's on the phone.
我想为你介绍乔纳森，他在电话上。
Hi Mr. Azar.
你好，阿扎尔先生。
Jonathan?
乔纳森？
Yeah, my name's Jonathan.
是的，我叫乔纳森。
Good morning, Jonathan.
早上好，乔纳森。
Good morning, how are you?
早上好，你好吗？
OK. Talk to me.
很好。跟我聊聊。
It's nice to meet you.
很高兴认识你。
Thank you.
谢谢。
So, Naomi's been explaining this challenge that you were put on, to call each of your kids. And then she explained to me that it only lasted three days.
所以，娜奥米一直在解释你接受的挑战，给你的每个孩子打电话。她还跟我说，那只持续了三天。
Right. [LAUGHS]
对。[笑]
What happened?
发生了什么？
Well, she gave me a challenge for a month. I just felt funny. I felt funny to tell them I love you and this and that. I felt-- it's not me. And that's why I could not take it more than three days.
好吧，她给了我一个月的挑战。我只是觉得滑稽。我觉得对他们说“我爱你”之类的话很滑稽。我觉得——那不是我。这就是为什么我坚持不过三天。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
It is not by word, it is by feeling. And all my children know that I love them, and I'll do everything for them. At the beginning, it was fun. But after three days, I felt a little bit phony.
这不是靠言语，是靠感觉。我所有的孩子都知道我爱他们，我会为他们做一切。起初，这很有趣。但三天后，我觉得有点虚伪。
Did your parents ever tell you that they loved you?
你的父母曾经告诉过你他们爱你吗？
Never. They never called me, I love you. But they loved me.
从来没有。他们从没对我大喊“我爱你”。但他们爱我。
And you knew that.
而你知道这一点。
I always felt that they loved me, because the society was different. I believe that parents should tell their children every once in a while, "I love you." But I think parents should tell-- maybe when they were small, of course we told them that we love them. But now they are all married, and you don't want to tell them "I love you."
我一直感觉到他们爱我，因为社会环境不同。我相信父母应该偶尔告诉孩子“我爱你”。但我觉得父母应该告诉——也许他们小的时候，当然我们告诉过他们我们爱他们。但现在他们都结婚了，你不想告诉他们“我爱你”。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Do you have children?
你有孩子吗？
I have a little girl, yeah.
我有个小女儿，是的。
I'm sure you tell her you love her every day.
我相信你每天都告诉她你爱她。
I do, yeah.
我确实说了，是的。
But how about when she is 25?
但当她25岁时呢？
We'll see, I guess.
到时候看吧，我想。
We'll see. That's right. That's right.
到时候看吧。没错。没错。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Maybe I should have done it. I don't know. Naomi, what difference-- did you feel lack of love if I did not do it?
也许我应该坚持下去。我不知道。娜奥米，有什么区别吗——如果我没做，你会觉得缺乏爱吗？
Well, I wanted you to succeed. When you say that you felt phony, maybe it was, like, you didn't actually-- you weren't hit with a wave of feeling love every day of the month. And so, for you, it didn't feel genuine to call on a Wednesday when you weren't actually feeling that kind of loving feeling, is that right?
嗯，我希望你成功。当你说你觉得虚伪时，也许是说，你并没有每天都被那种爱的浪潮击中。所以，对你来说，在星期三打电话时，如果你并没有真正感受到那种爱的感觉，确实会觉得不真实，是这样吗？
Uh-huh. You see, Jonathan, I love this girl the most. But it's just one hair above the rest. She is a hiker, she likes to travel, she has a bicycle. All the things I like.
嗯。你看，乔纳森，我最爱这个女儿。但这只比其余的人多出那么一点点。她是个远足者，她喜欢旅行，她有一辆自行车。所有我喜欢的东西。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
She has a bicycle.
她有一辆自行车。
Naomi, I wanted to ask you, in the first message, your dad says, "does it make any difference, let me know please." So, I guess, did it make a difference?
娜奥米，我想问你，在第一条信息里，你爸爸说“这有什么区别吗，请让我知道”。所以，我想，这有区别吗？
Yeah. It did make a difference.
有。确实有区别。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah. Because I know that you love me, but it's different to hear you say it. I was excited, and I was proud of you for doing it, Dad. Yeah.
是的。因为我知道你爱我，但听到你说出来感觉是不一样的。我当时很兴奋，爸爸，我为你这样做感到自豪。是的。
So maybe I'll start doing it again.
所以也许我会重新开始。
[LAUGHTER] I'll save all of those messages to you.
[笑声] 我会为你保存所有那些信息。
Jonathan Menjivar, he's a producer on our show. He is celebrating Father's Day with his daughter, Sasha, who is 16 months old.
乔纳森·门吉瓦尔，他是我们节目的制作人。他正在和16个月大的女儿萨沙一起庆祝父亲节。
Coming up, the guy who explained to us years ago on our program about the greatest phone message in the world. A phone message about why the Little Mermaid can go [BLEEP] herself. He's back, for Father's Day, with two daughters. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，是那位多年前在我们的节目中向我们解释世界上最伟大的电话留言的人。一个关于为什么小美人鱼可以去[消音]自己的电话留言。为了父亲节，带着两个女儿，他又回来了。稍后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际，节目继续。
It's This American Life , I'm Ira Glass. Today we have a special show for Father's Day this weekend about fathers trying to connect with their kids using whatever flawed means are at their disposal.
这是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天，为了这个周末的父亲节，我们有一个特别节目，关于父亲们试图利用他们掌握的任何有缺陷的手段与孩子们建立联系。
You know that adage that you don't really understand stuff your parents did until you become an adult yourself? I have a funny example of that that somebody emailed the radio show about. When Angie was growing up in this small town in Wisconsin, her dad did a lot of goofy stuff that she never thought twice about. He always worked swing shifts, so when should come home from school, he would usually be in the kitchen, packing his lunch to go off to work.
你知道那句格言吗，就是当你自己成为成年人之前，你并不真正理解父母所做的事情？关于这点，我有一个有趣的例子，有人给电台发了邮件。当安吉在威斯康星州的一个小镇长大时，她爸爸做了很多她从未多想的傻事。他总是做轮班工作，所以当她放学回家时，他通常在厨房里准备要去上班的午餐。
And every day when we would pack his lunch-- it was practically every day-- he went sing the Thermos song. I would watch him and he'd ask me about my day, and then he would sing me the Thermos song. So he would be, like, [SINGING] "I am picking out a Thermos, for you, for you, not an ordinary Thermos, for you, for you." It goes on and it's this goofy little song.
每天我们要准备他的午餐时——几乎是每天——他会唱“保温杯之歌”。我会看着他，他会问我一天的生活，然后他会唱给我听。他会这样唱，[唱歌]“我正在挑选一个保温杯，为你，为你，不是一个普通的保温杯，为你，为你。”这首歌很长，是个傻乎乎的小曲子。
Another thing was, every year when the new phone book came out-- I was from a really small town, so the phone book was probably an inch and a half think.
另一件事是，每年新电话簿出版时——我来自一个小镇，所以电话簿大概有1.5英寸厚。
Right.
对。
But he would freak out. And he'd run to the front door. And he be like, "The new phone book's here. The new phone book's here." Me and my brother would gather around, and he'd flip through all the pages and he'd be like, "Here we are. Our name's in print, our name's in print." Every single time, every year, we would do that.
但他会发疯。他会跑到前门。他会说，“新电话簿到了。新电话簿到了。”我和哥哥会围过去，他会翻遍所有页面说，“我们在这。我们的名字印在上面了，我们的名字印在上面了。”每次都是这样，每年，我们都会这样做。
So when I was in college, my roommate thought I was crazy. I was in the phone book for the first time. And I was like, "The phone book's here, the phone book's here, we have to find ourselves." And I would actually sing the Thermos song, too. Just randomly, when I would pack a lunch, you know you pick up things.
所以当我在大学时，我的室友以为我疯了。我第一次出现在电话簿上。我说，“电话簿到了，电话簿到了，我们必须找到自己。”我还真的唱了那个“保温杯之歌”。就是随机地，当我打包午餐时，你知道，你会养成习惯。
So. Once she gets to college, Angie happens to catch a old movie that she had never seen, Steve Martin's 1979 The Jerk .
所以，一旦她上了大学，安吉碰巧看了一部她从未看过的老电影，史蒂夫·马丁1979年的《阿呆闯学府》。
And it's really not very far into the movie that he gets a job in the gas station. He's really excited about working there. And the phone book comes. He freaks out. He just jumps around like my dad did. And we was, like, "The new phone book's here, the new phone book's here."
电影还没开始多久，他就在加油站找了一份工作。他对自己能在那工作感到非常兴奋。电话簿到了。他疯了。他像我爸爸一样跳来跳去。他说，“新电话簿到了。新电话簿到了。”
Oh my God. The new phone book's here. The new phone book's here.
天哪。新电话簿到了。新电话簿到了。
I wish I could get that excited about nothin'.
我希望我能对什么东西也这么兴奋。
Nothing, are you kidding? Page 73. Johnson, Navin R. I'm somebody now. Millions of people look at this book every day. This is the kind of spontaneous publicity, your name in print, that makes people.
没东西，你在开玩笑吗？第73页。约翰逊，纳文·R。我现在是个大人物了。每天有数百万人看这本书。这种自发的宣传，你的名字印在上面，这就是让人成功的原因。
And I immediately saw that, and I was like, holy crap. That's what we do. So I'm watching the movie, and then later on he's falls in love with-- I guess it's Bernadette Peters stars in the movie, I think?
我立刻看到了那一幕，我当时就想，该死。这就是我们做的。所以我看着电影，后来他爱上了——我想是伯纳黛特·彼得斯主演的？
Yeah.
对。
And he sings this song to her. He's like, "Honey, honey, I wrote you a song."
然后他给她唱了这首歌。他说，“宝贝，宝贝，我为你写了首歌。”
Honey, guess what, I wrote a song for you this morning.
宝贝，猜猜看，我今天早上为你写了首歌。
And he starts singing her this song.
然后他开始给她唱那首歌。
[SINGING] Oh, I'm picking out a Thermos for you. Not an ordinary Thermos for you.
[唱歌] 哦，我正在挑选一个保温杯，为你。不是一个普通的保温杯，为你。
At this point, I'm just like, whoa, wait a minute. Why is he doing that? And then I felt sort of wronged.
在那一刻，我就想，哇，等一下。他为什么要那样做？然后我感到有点被冒犯了。
And so did you call your dad?
那你给你爸爸打电话了吗？
Yeah. I called him up. I was like, hey dad, that's not yours. And he's, like, yeah, I know. And I was like, dad, it's The Jerk. And he's like, oh yeah. No, I love that movie. And I was like, did it ever occur to you that I'd never seen the movie? He was like, gosh, no, I never thought about it.
打了。我给他打电话。我说，嘿爸爸，那不是你的。他说，是的，我知道。我说，爸爸，那是《阿呆闯学府》。他说，哦，是的。不，我爱那部电影。我问，你有没有想过我从来没看过那部电影？他说，天哪，没有，我从来没想过。
Angie says it is impossible to imagine any part of the story happening with her mom. Lifting bits from an old Steve Martin film and planting them into a kid's life without ever thinking to mention where they came from. That is just a very dad-like behavior. When a dad sets the rules, it is his world and the kids have to live in it. Which brings us to the next act of our show, Act three, "Mr. Baby Monitor."
安吉说，很难想象她妈妈会做这种事。从史蒂夫·马丁的旧电影里剪辑片段，强行植入孩子的生活，却从不提及它们的出处。那是非常“爸爸式”的行为。当爸爸制定规则时，那是他的世界，孩子们必须生活在其中。这把我们带到了节目的下一部分，第三幕，“婴儿监视器先生”。
Jonathan Goldstein tells this story of a dad and how he runs his house.
乔纳森·戈德斯坦讲述了一个父亲和他如何管理家庭的故事。
My friend Josh is a stay-at-home dad. Recently, someone asked me what Josh did before he was a stay-at-home dad. And I said, he was a stay-at-home.
我的朋友乔希是一位全职居家爸爸。最近，有人问我乔希在当居家爸爸之前是做什么的。我说，他一直就是个居家的人。
Home is where Josh has always shined. Home being the place he'd become absorbed in his many projects. Meticulously categorizing his music collection or stockpiling yet-to-be-read newspapers into tilting monoliths. Or, much to his neighbor's sorrow, teaching himself to play the castanets. But now Josh's newest home project, the project that's taken over everything else, is the raising of his 20-month-old twin daughters, Matilda and Juliette. He brings to it a certain similar thoroughness.
家一直是乔希闪光的地方。家是他沉浸在许多项目中的地方。一丝不苟地整理他的音乐收藏，或将还没看的报纸囤积成倾斜的巨石阵。或者，令邻居悲伤的是，自学玩响板。但现在乔希最新的家庭项目，那个占据了所有其他项目的项目，是抚养他20个月大的双胞胎女儿，玛蒂尔达和朱丽叶。他对此投入了一种类似的彻底性。
Even in the old days, Josh was difficult to get out of the house. Scheduling a beer together often required the kind of constant back and forth one usually associates with lunar landings. But now, getting together is pretty much out of the question. None of our friends ever see him, and he pretty much never returns anyone's phone calls. People are starting to give up on Josh, and I guess I was starting to give up too. Until a recent conversation I had with his wife, LeeAnn.
即使在过去，乔希也很难离开家。安排一次聚会通常需要那种通常与登月有关的反复协商。但现在，聚会基本上是不可能的。我们的朋友从没见过他，他也几乎从不回任何人的电话。人们开始放弃乔希了，我想我也开始放弃了。直到我最近和他妻子莉安谈话。
"Please get him out of the house," she said. "Even just for an hour." If Josh acts with LeeAnn anywhere near the way he does with me-- that is, hostile, overly didactic, and so controlling as to forbid your use of certain words he doesn't approve of, a constantly growing roster that, at last check included, goo, bum, smoothie and lover-- the woman was in desperate need of a break.
“请带他出家门吧，”她说。“哪怕只是一个小时。”如果乔希对待莉安的方式和我差不多——也就是说，敌对、过度教条、控制欲极强，以至于禁止你使用某些他不批准的词汇（最后一次检查，这个不断增长的名单包括：软糖、屁股、奶昔和爱人）——那么这个女人确实迫切需要休息。
So I decide to just show up at his home with my tape recorder. And in the interest of full disclosure, I should probably also admit that I was motivated by a little something else. Actually missing the guy. A lot.
所以我决定带着我的录音机去他家。为了全面披露，我也应该承认我被另一件事激励了。我真的很想念这家伙。非常想。
As soon as I walk into the house, Josh starts in. He is standing at the top of the stairs, holding one of his twins, Juliette.
我一走进屋子，乔希就开始了。他站在楼梯顶端，抱着双胞胎之一，朱丽叶。
So, you know what? Try to keep a little bit of physical distance from her, because she gets-- like that would be not something to do. Like, stay over there.
所以，你知道吗？尽量和她保持一点物理距离，因为她变得——那不是该做的事。就像，待在那边。
Josh seems to think the microphone is making me appear sort of creepy.
乔希似乎认为麦克风让我看起来有点诡异。
Here you go, Boo Boo.
给你，嘘嘘。
But in his shorts and unkempt beard, talking in a voice reminiscent of Jennifer Tilly, it seems to me that he is the creepy one. Creepy and suspicious of why I wanted to record any of this, or do a story about him being a new dad in the first place.
但他穿着短裤，留着乱糟糟的胡子，用一种让人想起詹妮弗·提莉的声音说话，我觉得他才是那个诡异的人。诡异且怀疑我为什么要录下这些，或者为什么要做一个关于他作为新手爸爸的故事。
Just to say, the fact that you're recording this-- and so  I making myself [UNINTELLIGIBLE]-- makes me feel like the greasiest, dirtiest [BLEEP] on the face of the planet. It's actually like I'm prostituting my children. The kids are stripped down to their diapers, Josh is wearing a diaper, too. He says it makes the children more comfortable. I think he was wearing one long before he ever had kids.
只想说，你正在录音这件事——让我觉得我像是地球上最油腻、最肮脏的[消音]。这实际上就像我在把我的孩子当妓女一样。孩子们只穿着尿布，乔希也穿着尿布。他说这让孩子们更舒服。我觉得他在有孩子之前很久就开始穿了。
Yeah, oh, can you please tickle her toes? Yah. Ticky, ticky, ticky, ticky, ticky, ticky.
是的，哦，你能帮她挠挠脚趾吗？耶。挠挠，挠挠，挠挠。
Josh is protective. Last time I saw him, we took the kids for a walk around the block. And as they started to doze in their carriage, fearing they might be awoken, he shushed a revving car, as well as a boy bouncing a ball on the sidewalk. For Josh, being a dad means forcibly remodeling the world so that it conforms to the needs of his children. No matter what.
乔希很有保护欲。上次见到他时，我们带孩子们在街区散步。当她们在推车里开始打瞌睡时，担心她们会被吵醒，他甚至制止了一辆轰鸣的汽车，还有一个在人行道上拍球的男孩。对乔希来说，当爸爸意味着强行重塑这个世界，让它符合他孩子的需要。无论如何。
Let me give you-- if there's one word of advice I can give to new parents out there, it's kill your pets now.
让我给你——如果说我能给新手父母什么建议的话，那就是现在杀掉你们的宠物吧。
Yeah, where are the cats?
是的，猫在哪？
I repeat my earlier statement.
我重复我之前的声明。
While sitting in his yard, I notice an empty wooden rectangular box. Alive and well, two cats sit within it, sunning themselves. Josh tells me that the box is a sandbox. When I ask him where the sand is, I expect him to tell me that sand is too filthy and unsafe for children, that he prefers keeping a sandbox free of sand. But instead he tells me that they just haven't gotten around to filling it.
当坐在院子里时，我注意到一个空的木制长方形箱子。两只猫活蹦乱跳地坐在里面，晒着太阳。乔希告诉我那个箱子是个沙坑。当我问他沙子在哪时，我以为他会说沙子太脏而且不安全，孩子不适合玩，他更喜欢保持沙坑没有沙子。但相反，他告诉我说他们还没来得及填充沙子。
We have no time. And you know why we have no time? Because we have twins. Now, that word should be banned. You know what twins actually are? Two [BLEEP] babies at the same time. So that's what people should say, "Oh, I see you have two [BLEEP] babies at the same time. That must be [BLEEP] crazy. How do you manage that?" That's what it should be like. Because that's the reality.
我们没有时间。你知道为什么我们没时间吗？因为我们有双胞胎。现在，那个词应该被禁止。你知道双胞胎实际上是什么吗？同时有两个[消音]婴儿。所以人们应该说，“哦，我看你有两个同时存在的[消音]婴儿。那一定很[消音]疯狂。你怎么应付得过来？”应该这样说。因为这就是现实。
Because you think that twins doesn't get the idea across?
因为你认为“双胞胎”这个词不能表达意思？
That's correct. People think, oh, I raised-- particularly older people-- I raised two children, I raised three children. How hard could it be? They were all different ages. Children are very, very different at different developmental stages. Two [BLEEP] babies at the same time, very, very different. That's all. So nomenclaturally, that's what I have to contribute. That's my great contribution to parenting philosophy in America.
没错。人们以为，哦，我抚养过——特别是老年人——我抚养过两个孩子，三个孩子。那能有多难？她们都在不同的年龄。孩子们在不同的发育阶段表现非常非常不同。同时有两个[消音]婴儿，情况完全不同。就这样。所以从命名法角度看，这就是我的贡献。这就是我对美国育儿哲学的伟大贡献。
You feel like you always need to be around. You can't just leave the kids with LeeAnn.
你觉得你需要一直陪在她们身边。你不能只把孩子留给莉安。
That's correct. I don't currently quote, unquote "work." And you don't really need the quotes there. I don't make quote, unquote "money." Because I'm here all the time. It's also a certain style of parenting we have.
没错。我目前不“工作”。你真的不需要引号。我不赚“钱”。因为我一直在这儿。这也是我们的一种育儿风格。
Which is? How would you describe that style?
那是？你会怎么描述那种风格？
It's called attachment parenting. You try to foster a closeness, so you don't-- not so big on day care, at least in the early years. Not so big on nannies, things like that. More on having the parents present. With twins it's a very, very hard philosophy to put into action. You know, always got to be present. So I mean, I haven't gone out to a restaurant, I haven't gone out to a concert, or to a peep show, or anything in a long, long time.
它叫依恋育儿。你试图培养一种亲密度，所以你不会——不太赞成托儿所，至少在早期几年。不太赞成保姆之类的事。更多的是让父母在场。有了双胞胎，这是一种非常非常难付诸实践的哲学。你知道，必须一直在场。我的意思是，我已经很久很久没有去过餐馆、音乐会或脱衣舞秀了。
It's been over two years that you have just gone out and done something by yourself.
已经两年多了，你都没有自己出去做过什么事。
Generally speaking. The exception of an hour here, and hour there, which I usually used to go grocery shopping anyway. So technically speaking, no, I haven't. At all. Gone anywhere, done anything. At all.
总的来说是这样。除了偶尔有一个小时，我通常还是拿去买杂货了。所以从技术上讲，不，我没去过任何地方，没做过任何事。完全没有。
What with caring for the twins, sorry two [BLEEP] babies, neither he nor LeeAnn have gotten more than a few hours sleep in the past couple of nights. Nevertheless, Josh does admit that, as the girls are approaching their second birthday, things are starting to change. Starting to get a little bit easier. Which prompts me to boldly ask the burning question.
考虑到照顾双胞胎，对不起，两个[消音]婴儿，他和莉安过去几晚都没有睡超过几个小时。然而，乔希确实承认，随着女孩们快要两岁了，事情开始发生变化。开始变得轻松了一点。这促使我大胆地问了一个火热的问题。
So what do you say? I mean, you're talking about how it's hard to organize, and make use of the time. I mean, I'm here now. You want to go around the corner and get a souvlaki? You know, for old time's sake?
那你怎么看？我的意思是，你在说这很难安排，很难利用时间。我的意思是，我现在在这儿。你想去拐角处吃点烤肉卷吗？你知道，怀旧一下？
Not at this time of night. It can't be done. I mean, it could be done, but it'd be incredibly stress--
不是在这大半夜。这做不到。我的意思是，可以做到，但这会产生巨大的压——
Just for an hour, say. Forty-five minutes.
就一个小时，说好了。45分钟。
You have to understand that you know-- come to me in a year and we can go. But, you know.
你得明白，你知道——一年后再来找我，我们就可以去了。但是，你知道。
But, you, you--
但是，你，你——
Come to me in six months and we can go.
六个月后再来找我，我们就能去了。
But, but, but you were saying it's starting to change now.
但是，但是，但是你刚才说现在开始改变了。
Yeah, starting to change is not--
是的，开始改变并不代表——
You don't feel like you can get an hour--
你不觉得你可以腾出一个小时——
Let me tell you something, when you start to change your clothes, are you ready to walk outside on the street? If you only have your undershirt on and no pants? Knowing you, probably, that's OK. But for most normal people it's probably not the greatest thing in the world. You got a pair of socks and your junk's hanging out.
让我告诉你，当你开始换衣服时，你准备好光着身子直接走到街上了吗？如果你只穿了内衣没穿裤子？了解你，也许那也行。但对大多数正常人来说，这可能不是世界上最好的事情。你穿了双袜子，但命根子露在外面。
So when LeeAnn came to me, pleading, saying, please, get him out of the house, how do you answer to this? Do you think she doesn't know what she's talking about?
所以当莉安来找我，恳求说，求你了，带他出门吧，你怎么回答？你认为她不知道她在说什么吗？
No, of course she does. I say the same thing to her. No-- look, don't make too much of it. Come on in. Take your shoes off.
不，她当然知道。我对她也是这么说的。不——看，别太当回事。进来吧。把鞋脱了。
When we get back inside, in spite of the summer heat, Josh closes the living room window due to the fumes of an idling car parked in front of the house.
当我们回到屋里时，尽管有夏日的酷暑，乔希还是因为面前停着的空转汽车的尾气而关上了客厅的窗户。
The other thing is I'd probably-- if you weren't here-- I'd  probably yell out the window.
另一件事是我大概会——如果你不在这儿——我会对着窗外大喊。
Although the house is hot, the girls are in good spirits. and they are very, very adorable. But as I start to play with them, Josh tells me I'm not doing it right, and so he offers some helpful instruction.
虽然屋里很热，女孩们情绪不错，而且非常非常可爱。但当我开始和她们玩时，乔希告诉我我做得不对，于是他提供了一些有用的指导。
Tickle her [BLEEP] belly button. Okay. Here we go. Tickle, tickle, tickle. Tickle, tickle, tickle.
挠她的[消音]肚脐。好吧。开始吧。挠挠，挠挠，挠挠。挠挠，挠挠，挠挠。
It's inevitable that the girls will, some day, possibly soon, come to find Josh's neuroses, obsession and paranoia just as difficult as everyone else does. And it'll be integral for Uncle Jonny to be there, to commiserate, to trash talk.
女孩们有一天，可能很快，会发现乔希的神经质、强迫症和偏执和大家认为的一样难以忍受，这是不可避免的。而琼尼叔叔在那里发牢骚、说坏话对她们来说将是必不可少的。
Tickle tickle tickle. Oh, she wants to touch your head. Take your hat off.
挠挠挠挠挠挠。哦，她想摸你的头。把帽子脱了。
To nurture their annoyance with Josh so that one day it, too, can grow big and strong.
培养她们对乔希的厌烦，这样有一天，这种厌烦也能长得又大又强壮。
He doesn't have much hair.
他没什么头发。
No. It's moist.
没。他很潮湿。
Feel it. Feel it.
摸摸看。摸摸看。
Jonathan Goldstein is the host of the radio show Wiretap , which is heard on the CBC, and on many public radio stations in this country as well. Josh Karpati only allowed to let Jonathan come over and interview him for the radio if we mentioned his Twitter feed, so if you want to hear more words that Josh once banned, @jkarpati. That is the letter J, K- A- R- P- A- T- I. And yeah, follow if you want.
乔纳森·戈德斯坦是广播节目《窃听》的主持人，该节目在加拿大广播公司以及国内许多公共广播电台播出。乔希·卡帕蒂只允许乔纳森过来接受采访，前提是我们必须提到他的Twitter账号，所以如果你想听到更多乔希曾经禁用的词汇，@jkarpati。那是字母J，K-A-R-P-A-T-I。是的，想关注就关注吧。
Act four, "Bring your child to work detail." For fathers who are locked up for decades behind bars, family relationships suffer, as you'd imagine. Or even disappear. That is, unless, they decide to do something about it. Get a  little creative. Michael May has the story, from prison in east Texas.
第四幕，“带孩子上班任务”。对于那些被关在监狱里几十年的父亲来说，正如你所料，家庭关系会受损。甚至消失。除非他们决定对此做点什么。变得有点创意。迈克尔·梅带来了这个故事，来自东德克萨斯的一所监狱。
Daniel Johnson is 66 years old, and he's spent more than half of his life behind bars. It shows. He's pale, gaunt, and has lost most of his teeth. Before he went to prison, he'd fathered four children and built a successful insurance business. But Daniel had a dark side.
丹尼尔·约翰逊今年66岁，他大半辈子都在监狱里度过。这显而易见。他脸色苍白，形容枯槁，牙齿几乎掉光了。入狱前，他育有四个孩子，并建立了一家成功的保险生意。但丹尼尔有阴暗的一面。
I think it was a terrible ego problem I had. I used to be a debonair character, always athletic and I thought that women were pretty much in love with me. I was married at the time, had a mistress on the side. One of those kind of guys that flirted and bounced around from town to town. I was a businessman, often on trips and so forth. And I had women wherever I went.
我想那是我当时糟糕的自负问题。我曾经是一个优雅的角色，一直很爱运动，我认为女人们几乎都爱上了我。那时我结婚了，外面还有个情妇。那种在城镇之间调情和奔波的男人。我是个生意人，经常出差等等。我走到哪里都有女人。
In 1970, he went through a bitter divorce and moved from Illinois to Houston. He remarried. Then, in 1977, Daniel met a woman who worked at his apartment complex, and he says they made plans to meet. When he made his move, she said no.
1970年，他经历了一场痛苦的离婚，从伊利诺伊州搬到了休斯顿。他再婚了。然后，在1977年，丹尼尔遇到了一位在他公寓大楼工作的女性，他说他们计划见面。当他采取行动时，她说不。
I had something to drink that day, and when she threw up the rejection, my ego, I don't think tolerated that back then, and I just forced myself upon her.
那天我喝了点酒，当她拒绝时，我的自负——我不认为那时的我能容忍拒绝，我就强迫了她。
Daniel was convicted of rape and given a sentence of life in prison. Since then, he's gone through a successful reconciliation with his victim, which she initiated. But his family relationships never recovered.
丹尼尔因强奸罪被判终身监禁。从那时起，他与受害者达成了成功的和解，这是受害者主动发起的。但他的家庭关系再也没有恢复。
I really abandoned my children. Bradley will be 48. Michael is 46. Jacqueline is 45. And Tyler would be 34. When I lost them, through my own criminal acts, of course, that put a big void in my heart.
我真的抛弃了我的孩子们。布拉德利现在48岁。迈克尔46岁。杰奎琳45岁。泰勒现在应该34岁了。当我因为自己的犯罪行为失去他们时，当然，那在我心中留下了一个巨大的空洞。
I remember staying with my mother, like for, I think age four to five. But for some reason my mother lost custody.
我记得和我妈妈待在一起，大概是四到五岁的时候。但出于某种原因，我妈妈失去了抚养权。
That's Jesse Johnson. Same last name as Daniel. As you'll hear it's an odd coincidence. By appearance, the two inmates couldn't be more different. Daniel is white and weathered. And Jesse is 34 years old. Black with youthful good looks. But they have a lot in common. They're both in prison for sexual assault, and they both know what it feels like to lose family.
那是杰西·约翰逊。和丹尼尔同样的姓氏。正如你即将听到的，这是一个奇怪的巧合。从外表上看，这两个囚犯再不同不过了。丹尼尔白人且饱经风霜。而杰西今年34岁。黑人，带着青春的英俊外表。但他们有很多共同点。他们都因性侵犯罪入狱，他们都知道失去家庭是什么滋味。
Jesse never really knew his dad, and after he was separated from his mother at five, his grandmother had to take him in. He says she never really took to him, used to beat him. And he ran away when he was 11.
杰西从来没真正认识过他爸爸，在五岁和母亲分开后，他祖母不得不收留他。他说她从没真正喜欢过他，经常打他。他在11岁时跑了。
Daniel and Jesse connected almost immediately when they met five years ago. It was during rec time on the yard at Eastham prison in east Texas.
五年前他们见面时，丹尼尔和杰西几乎立刻就建立了联系。那是在东德克萨斯伊斯特汉监狱操场的休息时间。
We were out in the yard and I pretty much always stayed to myself. Exercised by myself and so forth. And walked around. And he was out in the yard, sitting there and as I often would do.
我们在操场上，我几乎总是独来独往。自己锻炼之类。走来走去。他就在操场上，坐在那里，像我经常做的那样。
I surely was, that's what it was. And he walked by and he asked me what was I reading.
我确实是，事情就是这样。他走过我身边，问我在读什么。
And I'd walk by and know some of the books that he'd be reading. And they were all motivational type books.
我走过时知道他在读的一些书。而且它们都是励志类的书。
And I showed him the book The Secret . Then he shared with me this the book, Think and Grow Rich by Napoleon Hill. And I was like, yeah, I read that one. I liked that book. You know, saying like he read it too.
我给他看了《秘密》那本书。然后他跟我分享了拿破仑·希尔的《思考致富》。我说，是的，那本我读过。我喜欢那本书。你知道，意思是说他也读过。
And that's how it started out.
事情就是这样开始的。
The two lived in different cell blocks, but they started meeting each other on the yard almost every day. And an informal mentorship began to develop. Jesse helped Daniel get in shape, and Daniel answered Jesse's questions about how to start a personal training business.
两人住在不同的监舍，但他们开始几乎每天在操场上见面。一种非正式的导师关系开始形成。杰西帮丹尼尔塑形，丹尼尔回答杰西关于如何开始个人训练生意的问题。
If he try to work out for hisself, he'll over do it. He's very competitive. And so we'll go out on the rec yard every morning. And we work out every day, and we jog. He does my exercises and my aerobics.
如果他试图自己锻炼，他会过度。他很好胜。所以我们每天早上都会去操场。我们每天锻炼，我们慢跑。他做我的练习和我的有氧运动。
So what would you tell him about your experience?
那你对他说过你的经历吗？
How I would go out and meet customers. How you meet and greet people. How you get business. How you advertise.
我是如何出去见客户的。如何见面和迎接人们。如何做生意。如何做广告。
Each of them told me they were happy to find someone that didn't just want to talk about street life. Drugs and women and crime. As their friendship developed, they began talking about things besides exercise and business. Personal stuff.
他们每个人都告诉我，很高兴能找到一个不只谈论街头生活的人。毒品、女人和犯罪。随着友谊的发展，他们开始谈论除了锻炼和生意之外的事情。私人的事情。
Then he would tell me about his family. And that's what really made me get close to him. I started to feel open, because I wanted a family. I wanted to know how it feels to grow up to be loved. And he grew up in a loving home. You know, with a mother and a father. He was in a good environment, good neighborhood, good community. And I was, like, envious. I always wanted that kind of life. And really, I always wanted a father.
然后他会告诉我关于他家人的事。那就是真正让我和他亲近的原因。我开始感到开放，因为我想要一个家庭。我想知道长到被爱是什么感觉。他长在一个充满爱的家里。你知道，有父亲和母亲。他处于一个好的环境，好的邻里，好的社区。我当时很嫉妒。我一直想要那种生活。而且真的，我一直想要一个父亲。
I started to think about him as my dad, I would say, in May of '09. In May. But I just kept it to myself.
我想大概是在09年5月，我开始把他当爸爸。在五月。但我只是把它放在心里。
And then, one day, it slipped out. Jesse was talking to Daniel and he called him Dad. It felt like the most natural thing in the world. Daniel had already taken to calling him son.
然后，有一天，它脱口而出。杰西在和丹尼尔说话，他叫他“爸爸”。这感觉就像世界上最自然的事情。丹尼尔已经习惯叫他“儿子”了。
He told me one day, he said, you know-- and he was looking at me as a father anyway-- he kind of called me Dad, you know. He said, when I was born, I didn't have a father on my birth certificate.
他有一天告诉我，他说，你知道——无论如何他都在看着我像父亲一样——他有点叫我爸爸。他说，我出生时，我的出生证明上没有父亲。
I wanted him to adopt me as his son. And I wanted to have him as my father. And he was in agreeance with it. He was, like, "I'd love to have you as a son." And I was like, yeah? Yeah.
我希望他收养我为子。我希望他做我的父亲。他同意了。他说，“我很乐意收养你做儿子。”我说，是吗？是的。
I said, you know, there's a big void in my heart, too, Jesse. I said, I've lost my children. And I said, it would wonderful for me to have a son. I'll adopt you.
我说，你知道，我心里也有个巨大的空洞，杰西。我说，我失去了我的孩子们。我说，如果能有个儿子对我来说太棒了。我要收养你。
That's right. They decided they wanted to legally become father and son. And, believe it or not, even in prison, this is possible. Turned out to be a simple procedure for an adult to adopt another adult in Texas. Both parties have to agree to it, and a judge must sign off on the adoption papers. Daniel filed the paperwork and then waited. Months went by.
没错。他们决定在法律上成为父子。相信我，即使在监狱里，这也可能。事实证明，成年人在德克萨斯州收养另一个成年人是一个简单的程序。双方都必须同意，法官必须在收养文件上签字。丹尼尔提交了文书工作，然后等待。几个月过去了。
And finally the judge wrote me a letter. And he said, "Mr. Johnson, why do you want to adopt him?" And in reply to that letter, I said, "There's a lot of love of a father within me. This love has found a child. It's found a home. It's someone I can call my son, who is not perfect, and I'm far from perfect. And we're going to do just fine, because I've accepted him, in my heart, as my son."
最后法官给我写了一封信。他说，“约翰逊先生，你为什么要收养他？”在回复那封信时，我说，“我心中有很多父亲的爱。这种爱找到了一个孩子。它找到了一个家。他是我可以称之为儿子的某人，他不完美，我也远非完美。我们会过得很好，因为我已经在心里接受他为我的儿子了。”
When I asked them why they felt so strongly that they wanted to go this far, they said all kinds of things. It validated their relationship, it bound them together by law. But what it came to is that each of them was missing the kind of relationship the mattered to them most. They couldn't control much in their lives, or fix the past, but they could do this.
当我问他们为什么如此强烈地想要走到这一步时，他们说了各种各样的事情。它验证了他们的关系，它在法律上将他们捆绑在一起。但关键在于他们每个人都失去了对他们最重要的那种关系。他们无法控制生活中的很多事情，也无法弥补过去，但他们可以这样做。
I thought it was just God sent that he didn't have a relationship with his children, and I didn't have a relationship with my father. He fulfilled that spot that I always wanted. I always wanted some male figure in my life, somebody that I can look up to that had achieved something, that had done some things in life that I can say, hey, I want to do that. And someone that would just be there for me, that whenever I messed up, they wouldn't criticize me, they wouldn't hit me, they wouldn't be verbally abusive with me.
我觉得那是上帝的旨意，因为他没有和他的孩子们建立关系，而我也没有和我父亲建立关系。他填补了我一直想要的那个位置。我一直想要生活中的某个男性形象，我可以仰望的、取得过成就的、在生活中做过一些我可以对他说“嘿，我想做那个”的人。而且是一个会一直支持我的人，无论我搞砸了什么，他们都不会批评我，不会打我，不会在言语上虐待我。
He would never be that way towards me. If he saw any of my shortcomings, my weaknesses, he would just inspire me. Like, that's OK, you can do better, take your time.
他永远不会那样对我。如果他看到我的任何缺点、弱点，他只会激励我。就像，没关系，你可以做得更好，慢慢来。
I told him, I told him several times, son, you're just a younger me packaged a little bit differently.
我告诉过他，我告诉过他好几次，儿子，你只是年轻一点的我，包装得有点不同而已。
Finally, they heard back from a judge.
最后，他们收到了法官的回复。
Could you read the last paragraph.
你能读一下最后一段吗？
Yes. "It is hereby ordered, adjudged and decreed, that Jesse Lewis Johnson, born March 5, 1977, in Liberty County, Texas, is the adopted son of petitioner Daniel K. Johnson for all purposes."
可以。“特此命令、裁定并判定，1977年3月5日出生于德克萨斯州利伯蒂县的杰西·刘易斯·约翰逊，为请愿人丹尼尔·K·约翰逊之养子，具有一切效力。”
The reactions at the prison were mixed. Daniel was in a wing of old timers who had no problem with the adoption. Jesse was in a high security wing, with younger guys, and it made some of them uncomfortable. Rumors circulated that the relationship was sexual. And the fact that it was an older white inmate adopting a black inmate made it worse.
监狱里的反应不一。丹尼尔在老人们的监区，他们对收养没意见。杰西在高安全监区，和年轻的家伙们在一起，这让他们中的一些人不舒服。谣言四起，说这种关系是性关系。而且是一位年长的白人囚犯收养了一位黑人囚犯的事实让情况更糟。
Jesse tried to ignore the talk, but then he got attacked by a prisoner who snuck into his cell. Officials decided to send Jesse to another prison entirely. They said it was for his own safety. But Daniel and Jesse believed they separated them simply because they didn't approve of the adoption.
杰西试图忽视这些流言，但后来他被一个溜进他监舍的囚犯袭击了。官员们决定把杰西送到另一所监狱。他们说是为了他自己的安全。但丹尼尔和杰西相信，他们把他们分开仅仅是因为他们不赞成收养。
Now Jesse is at the Polunsky Unit, a prison an hour or so away.
现在杰西在波伦斯基监狱，一个一小时车程之外的监狱。
I feel rather lonely. I've been depressed a lot. I don't exercise as much as I used to no more. He writes me letters. We write, we correspond. But it's not the same.
我觉得很孤独。我经常抑郁。我不再像过去那样锻炼了。他给我写信。我们写信，我们通信。但这不一样。
Jesse's petitioned the courts to try to get them moved back together again. But that doesn't look likely. They've also appealed Jesse's case to try to reduce his 60-year sentence. But the reality is, Jesse could be in prison long after Daniel is dead.
杰西已经向法院请愿，试图让他们重新住在一起。但这看起来不太可能。他们还对杰西的案子提起了上诉，试图减少他的60年刑期。但现实是，杰西可能在丹尼尔去世很久之后还会在监狱里。
So we're going to see Jessie in an hour or so. Do you have a message for him?
所以我们一小时左右就要去见杰西了。你有什么话要带给他吗？
You bet I do. Tell him I said I love him, I miss him. And to keep the faith, as we do. That we're going to see this thing through. And we're going to be together again. We're going to have a life out there in the streets. And tell him that I'm very, very proud of the courage he's displaying. Very proud of him.
你打赌我有。告诉他我说我爱他，我想他。并像我们做的那样，保持信念。我们会挺过难关的。我们会再次在一起。我们会在街上过上好日子。告诉他，我非常非常为他展现出的勇气感到自豪。非常为他骄傲。
Michael May, he's the managing editor at the Texas Observer .
迈克尔·梅，他是《德克萨斯观察家》的主编。
[MUSIC - "MY BABY'S DADDY" BY B ROCK AND THE BIZZ LYRICS]
[音乐——“我宝贝的爸爸”]
Our program is produced today by Robyn Semien, and myself with  Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, Jonathan Menjivar, Lisa Pollak, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Eric Mennel, music help from Jessica Hopper and Damien Grave. Seth Lind is our production manager, Emily Condon is our office manager. Jen Berman is filling in as our West coast producer.
我们今天的节目由罗宾·塞米恩制作，我和亚历克斯·布隆伯格、本·卡尔霍恩、简·费尔特斯、莎拉·柯尼格、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、丽莎·波拉克、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克共同制作。我们的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。制作协助来自埃里克·门内尔，音乐协助来自杰西卡·霍珀和达米安·格雷夫。塞思·林德是我们的制作经理，艾米丽·康顿是我们的办公室经理。詹·伯曼临时担任我们的西海岸制作人。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for a program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who's always trying to convince me that I am his favorite public radio host, and not Terry Gross. I finally asked him why.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播国际发行。WBEZ对节目的管理监督由我们的老板托雷·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他总是试图说服我我是他最喜欢的公共广播主持人，而不是特里·格罗斯。我终于问他为什么。
Because she is my favorite. That was a joke. And now I feel awful for making that joke.
因为她是我最喜欢的。那是个笑话。现在我为开了那个玩笑感到糟糕。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。